[Music]
davos is the scene
everybody was there
you have ceos from some of the biggest
companies in the world heads of state
president was there i don't remember
anyone taking coronavirus seriously
everyone's always enthusiastic at davos
no one makes friends there by predicting
doom and gloom
this seems to be the decade of shared
success
together we can together we
will i was reticent to say anything
because being a scientist driven by
facts and data in the absence of facts
and data i didn't want to make any
conjecture so i remember in retrospect i
probably made
statements that were perhaps too neutral
i think all the right things are
happening i mean you've seen
some of the actions the chinese
government has taken i know critical
disease control agencies around the
world are getting really active so we
all have to wait and see there's a lot
we don't know
i don't think i was pressing it in
saying
the economic trajectory the u.s economy
would continue in 2020.
you know people are relatively confident
that global growth will sustain through
2020 the chance of an economic slowdown
barring some sort of an exogenous event
we had an exogenous event i guess i was
right about that
i remember watching ceo of goldman sachs
on the dj booth
at a salesforce party just like 10 deep
shoulder to shoulder it all feels like a
totally different planet now
[Music]
these are people who should have had the
best sight lines
in the world into what was going on
these
are companies that have operations in
china where this virus had been
circulating for weeks
and at retrospect it probably should
have informed how we approached things
here because we were
what about two months behind them there
was a sense that
the economy was just too strong and
america was just
too resilient even as some parts of the
economy are showing positive signs
what happened during the month of march
will fundamentally reshape american
business for the next decade
march started on a very high note and it
ended with the economy just
in complete tatters in that 31 days
where just everything changed
so
[Music]
economic fears and many unknowns
rattling investors
all non-essential businesses shall close
their physical workplaces
police were called after some customers
started fighting over toilet paper and
water
this is our new reality right now it is
absolutely staggering where we find
[Music]
ourselves
looks like an n95 how'd you get that
happy to do it happy to do it i want to
be able to go back and look at it for
posterity's sake
we're really good at opening hotels but
if you were to ask me in the 36 or seven
years i've been doing this
how many hotels have i actually presided
over
closing it would be a very very short
list
i'm currently sitting actually in the
background lounge at bellagio
this building is vacant it's a bit
surreal
it's very different this is our um
trading desk so for our agricultural
commodities and you can you can see
that it it is empty typically it's very
busy
it's very noisy we designed this
headquarters campus in which i'm sitting
for about 5
000 people right now there are
roughly 300 people on a good day
i started putting out a friday note to
employees
on friday the 13th which was most
people's
last day in the office it said
friday march 13th i will stop comparing
this week to last week
we are in unchartered territory first
take care of yourselves and your
families as we run our business
follow company and local guidance use
judgment and humanity with individual
situations
show leadership with people who are
worried and remember we have a company
to run
[Music]
i'm chris nacetta ceo of hilton i'm the
senior vice president of corporate
affairs at 3m
i'm the head of manufacturing for toyota
motor north america
i'm the ceo of novartis i'm jeff blue's
president
and chief operating officer ceo and
chairman of procter gamble
chief executive officer of imax
corporation i am
chairman and ceo of cargill we're in the
privileged position of making food
chairman and ceo of goldman sachs acting
ceo
and president of mgm resorts
international ceo of u.s wealth
management for j.p morgan
deputy commissioner and chief operating
officer of the nba
so coming into 2020 the u.s is in year
11 of the longest
economic expansion since world war ii
millions of jobs have been added to the
economy
the stock market keeps hitting record
heights it looked like 2020 was going to
be another good year
new year's going into 2020 felt like any
other new year's
we were seven months into our fiscal
year and things were going well
i was two weeks into my job as a
first-time ceo
we had record box office of over a
billion dollars
you know when we look back we see an
auto market that was pretty hot
actually our sales were plus six percent
our earnings for plus 18
we were looking forward to bringing on a
new aircraft type the airbus 220.
how we would evolve the presentation of
our game
digitally we were all sort of having a
similar conversation about like gosh
times are good but
there's just sort of this haunting
feeling like
something's out there
the pandemics showed that the that
strong economy that it was
thin it was a veneer of strength in that
companies were were profitable making a
lot of money and unemployment was
low but you know it really exposed these
weaknesses where
wages had not really moved people are
not by and large wealthier than they
were
10 years ago the jobs that we saw grow
the most tended to be of the alternative
variety
uh whether it's contingent work
part-time work uh independent work gig
work
and that also brought to that a certain
amount of you know
fragility companies have spent trillions
of dollars over the last decade buying
back their own stock and paying
dividends
profits were growing but you might have
worried about for example
the the rate of rich companies are not
reinvesting into their businesses or
into the economy the classic case of you
know a lot of short-term orientation
without kind of big investments into the
future
the modern economy it's powered by
technology and it's this just in time
it's
perfectly efficient and in some ways it
is in some ways that's been really good
for
consumers in particular but you know the
flip side of efficiency is resiliency
there's no fat baked in there's no
cushion for when things get bad a
mysterious respiratory illness has
healthcare workers on alert
at least 45 people have contracted the
virus believed to be connected to
animals at a market in central china
png has people all over china we don't
have plants
in wuhan we have a distribution center
so as soon as this happened
our first concern was making sure we
took care of our employees
we knew there was some sort of emerging
viral issue in december our health and
safety team had
flagged in wuhan because we have five
hotels in wuhan
something's going on it felt like a just
china issue
for us because a lot of what we make is
for domestic consumption
and so certainly the impacts that we
looked at implications that we looked at
were largely limited to china and
perhaps parts
of southeast asia at that time i don't
think anybody thought
even when this was impacting macau and
china that it would distance itself this
close to us here
and end up in our ultimate shutdown
so there's this disconnect between the
sort of bad
rumblings out there and the bad
headlines coming out of china and across
europe
and the u.s stock market which just
keeps going up i mean it hits
record high after record high in
february
looking back it seems like hubris but
investors often don't see what's right
in front of them
coronavirus was on the horizon but our
investor day was one of the most
bullish and exciting that we've ever had
i remember talking to a very very
prominent investor super bowl weekend
down in miami
where we had a discussion where both of
us said boy
it seems like there's a lot more risk in
this virus
becoming a bigger issue than the markets
pricing in
on february 11th we've been asked to
participate in the opening bill ceremony
for nasdaq in celebration of our 20th
anniversary
happy 20th uh to jblu
i had the pleasure of appearing on
squawk box in the morning and was
specifically asked whether or not we
were seeing any
impact from the coronavirus you want to
start with coronavirus sure
is it impact is it really impacting
things in here in the united states
right now
you know for jetblue it's not impacting
uh jetblue in any meaningful way
boy was i wrong and there is a headline
that i think will live with me until i
retire from this industry
the chinese government basically shut
the country down and put the entire
populace under quarantine
now that had an immediate impact on
toyota's operations there we couldn't
make cars we couldn't sell cars
we have over 700 screens now
which is one percent of the screens in
the country and chinese new year is the
biggest film-going week
for us of the year in china we typically
do 10
of our year in one week and then we
heard
every theater in china was closed and
then a day later they said
none of the big chinese movies would be
released
what was the biggest part of our year
was reduced to nothing
overnight we produce about 70 billion
doses of medicine a year
in over 150 countries we had to make the
decision to
send all of our china operations home
which is over 10 000
people i think i began to wonder now is
this something
really big movement around china
especially around
the ube province was being restricted so
we had to let
both our employees know and more broadly
we communicated that this could have a
ripple effect
through other supply chains it wasn't
clear at that time how significant it
would be
we started having meetings almost every
other day
to really understand how did we how do
we pull together the right teams
assessing the the demand the supply
chain challenges
we worked together for everything from
sourcing making sure that we had the
critical raw materials available
in order to be able to manufacture
respirators
gearing up the equipment so that we
could run 24 7
everywhere around the world by the end
of february
we had mobilized a crisis management
team
i was meeting with my cfo on a regular
basis thinking
very long and hard about liquidity we
were modeling
every weekend looking at these numbers
that i think looked horrific it looked
like nothing i've ever seen
only to be outdone by the numbers i saw
the next weekend
which only got outdone by the numbers i
saw the following week
as it went further and further into the
abyss
i remember the management team meeting
that i had with my team
on march 4th where we all sat in the
same conference room together
jamie came and spoke to us for an hour
and he said to us
you should go read the history of the
spanish flu pandemic
in 1918.
[Music]
it was a early brush fire
in the spring summer of that year
it kind of went away and then in the
fall it came back and it killed 50
million people
and he said this is going to be severe
35 fatalities are linked to the life
care center in kirkland that is the
hardest hit facility
when i saw pictures of that nursing home
outside of seattle
where families couldn't get to see their
family members inside the nursing home
because the virus had
had essentially taken that facility over
the heartbreaking pictures of people
with their noses pressed up against the
window
to try and communicate with their loved
ones that struck home with me
airlines is where you first started to
see the disruption from the virus
as we stepped into march we started
seeing a fairly rapid decline of
customer bookings an increase in
customer no-show rates
and just overall changing customer
sentiment we knew we were
in something very different than what
we'd experienced before very different
than sar is very different than
zika and quite frankly very different
than 9 11.
our occupancies are quickly from the
third week in february
to the first week in march almost fell
in half in some of our luxury brands
but it was really where our group
business was because of the
international visitation that was
impacted
that time was a hectic time early in
march
government started putting restrictions
on large gatherings
that's when we started in that early
march time frame
really thinking about we may have to
play games without fans
i sat down with my cfo and i said to him
if the world shuts down what do our
financials look like
what's our burn rate how do we stop
spending money
[Music]
we called all our managers and we said
um cancel
all costs we just said you know stop it
right now
because we don't know what the future uh
entails
we pulled all our levers on liquidity
early because the reality is
cash is king i don't know how deep it's
going
and so to protect the business i've got
to have make sure that we have enough
cash
we have a billion 750 credit facility
we've pulled it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think this event for us and the
realization of probably where we were
going
hit the weekend of march 8th 9th and
10th
[Music]
we were fortunate we were hosting 15 000
people for a ufc fight we had bruno mars
at the park theater
but the reality was over at mirage we
were hosting a women's leadership
conference
one of the guest speakers was sick and
contracted covid19
a guest speaker an event of scale about
eight or nine hundred ladies
was in vip receptions went to several
restaurants went to several shows
met many people shook a lot of our
employees hands
it became a little daunting and thinking
about how are we going to handle this
going forward
when investors do finally pull their
head out of the sand they do it really
quickly
and the market starts to tank fast so on
march 9th
the market barely gets open
stocks fall so fast that it triggers
what they call a circuit breaker which
is basically a timeout it was put in
place after the 1987 crash
and it's basically an automatic halt
everyone go back to your corner
think about what you've done take a deep
breath and we'll try this again in 15
minutes
it hadn't been triggered in 20 years it
was a sign that
people were panicking investors were
running for the exits
and they couldn't get out fast enough
march 11th for a lot of people is the
day that this became
real very real very quickly we have
therefore made
the assessment that kovid 19
can be characterized as a pandemic
to keep new cases from entering our
shores
we will be suspending all travel from
europe
to the united states for the next 30
days
on march 11 we had a board meeting and
the topic of that board meeting was how
we were going to deal with the
coronavirus there was an understanding
that
yes we might actually have to play some
games without fans and at the time it
seemed
unthinkable and then of course that
night
uh is when we got our first confirmed
positive with rudy gobert
and we knew right then that we had to
suspend the season
tonight has been postponed you are all
[Music]
what brought a lot of that home for
people was that they watched it happen
in real time there's still games
happening
this is crazy this can't be true i mean
it's not within the realm of
possibilities it's just to seem more
like out of a movie than reality
and then very quickly people are looking
back at a press conference that rico
bear had given
where he makes a joke out of the whole
thing and it's touching all these
microphones
it just starts to sink in that like this
is not a joke
i remember thinking i wonder what
they're going to talk about on espn
it's a sports network and sports are
shutting down
and then thinking we sell food
with everything from whether it's ground
beef or
in you know sweeteners that go into the
sodas that are served with these
stadiums
what's this gonna mean for our customers
and you quickly go to start thinking
about
second and third order consequences as
stadiums and restaurants and places of
public gathering
start to close what does that mean for
our customers for their business
what does it mean for our business and
what does it mean for our employees
march 12th was the last day i've been in
the office
march 12th also was the day that the
market
took a severe downturn and for our 5000
advisors the average industry age of an
advisor are in their mid-50s and they've
seen many of these cycles and many
people remember
0809 but we also have a number of
advisors who were in their 30s
and they don't remember 08 and 09 and
that likely was the worst day of their
career and they hadn't seen volatility
like that
we also have a number of clients who had
probably never seen volatility like that
first-time investors
i was surprised at how hard
imax's stock got hit because we were
incredibly crushed
our stock had been trading generally in
the 20
range and it went down to six or seven
dollars within a matter of days when i
was allowed i actually
went into the market and i bought some
stock but i thought i would also be
sending a message
uh to our shareholders that i believed
in the company and i believe we could
survive this
march 12th stands out in so far as i was
on a flight to boston visiting with our
crew members on a pre-planned trip
the questions being asked changed almost
overnight
the questions our crew members started
asking were not just about my health
but am i gonna have a job what's this
gonna do to jetblue can we survive this
it all came to a crescendo at that point
in time
when you realize that this is a much
bigger thing than anybody expected
we saw many of our advised clients move
and de-risk and get into cash or
short-term cash-like strategies
not surprisingly particularly our
clients who are nearing retirement just
wanted to
play it safe the advisors were still
going into the branches
because we were trying to stay open for
our clients as long as possible markets
were super volatile
people wanted to meet with their advisor
new york state on pause
a statewide order for people to stay at
home
we must enact an immediate stay-at-home
order today
so there's a whole group of companies
whose business models just don't make
sense
when there's a pandemic going on bars
restaurants
movie theaters sports stadiums casinos
anything that involves having lots of
people in close quarters
just doesn't work so those shut down
basically overnight
i made a lot of phone calls and i said
you know we should be leaders in this
let's not wait we should be upfront that
it's the right message that we're really
concerned
about the health and safety of our
customers to be fair to the people i was
talking to
blockbusters were scheduled to open soon
they had pre-sold tickets to theaters
and this lunatic
is saying shut down
what happened in the early into middle
part of march was
we were constantly adjusting to see if
we could maintain production
but there was a point in time in that
time frame
where a number of jurisdictions
basically said we're shutting down
our pipelines by design uh pretty thin
you know we don't carry a lot of
inventory that's the toyota way
inventory is waste when our production
stopped it had the impact of
almost drying up the typical you know 90
to 120 days worth of inventory that we
we might have for certainly for some of
our more popular models
now it's much less than that you know in
ways where we are
living hand to mouth to make sure that
we satisfy the demand of customers
we got one more bad news as you know the
market went the heck
our occupancies were going down at one
point our forecast for this building
bellagio
was like single digit became clear to us
that we were going to have to close
in this state we are the largest
employer largest payer of taxes
we are this community's economy
we had made a decision on the 14th to
close everything we notified the
governor on sunday afternoon
and by sunday at six o'clock that night
he had gone here in nevada on the
television
and mandated a closure the most
effective course of action
is to direct all nevadans to stay home
and for non-essential businesses
to close to the public for 30 days
we found ourselves in a closed mode for
us
that means about 270 million a month in
expenses
it's our burn rate
there was no choice there was no
business there were there were no
revenues there was no demand
even if you've been able to you know
reduce your workforce you still have to
pay your debt service
you still got to pay utilities and taxes
and all of these costs
no business is built for zero revenues
it's just not done the dow has its worst
single day in history i mean just
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars of stock market value is just
evaporating we were watching changes
in markets we were watching companies
borrow more aggressively
and one of the things that we started
talking about was there had always been
a stigma
associated with borrowing from the fed
window so collectively the ceos of the
eight large banks
got on a call together and we said does
it make sense for us
to all just borrow you know a nominal
amount
to show that we're all in unison that
this is not something that should have
stigma if it's necessary
to keep the banking system you know
functioning smoothly for our clients
we're you know we're all prepared to do
it
hilton hilton is the canary in the coal
mine this is an incredibly well
capitalized amazing
dominant global company that actually
doesn't own many hotels it just collects
royalties
down from like 120 to 50. okay it's
going to zero
okay along with every other hotel
company bill lachman is a well-known
hedge fund investor you buy stakes and
companies and is pretty vocal about his
opinions on them
his big position in hilton and he went
on cnbc and said among other things that
that stock might go to zero
you say hilton is going to zero i mean
because no business
can survive a period of 18 months
without revenue and as he's talking
the market is just falling and falling
and falling and it eventually triggers
another circuit breaker
i think he was trying to make a point
which was people should be taking this
covet 19 thing very seriously
because it could have a devastating
impact and reality is he was right
[Music]
we saw our revenue go from nearly 20
million dollars a day to you know zero
and even negative
almost overnight a number of states were
putting into place
travel quarantines you had governors and
others talking about you know flying
only for essential travel
in march our cash burn was about 15
million dollars a day
when you start doing the math you
realize very quickly that
uh there's an end point where you just
frankly run out of money
and the questions that we had to address
to our crew members were
what are we doing to cut costs standing
down projects freezing hiring
and looking at any level we could pull
to try to reduce our cash burn
it became very apparent that the amount
of flying that we were doing was going
to have to be reduced significantly
and the operational complexity of doing
that it's not just limited to
changing people's shifts we have this
fleet of over 260 aircraft
and where do you park all those planes
we needed to
park them out in the desert
[Music]
it was a record-breaking fall for u.s
retail sales in march
and then there are companies that aren't
forced to shut down but like they don't
have any customers anymore
there's just a total collapse in demand
people stopped
shopping they just stopped going to
stores this is the biggest
decline in retail sales since the
government started keeping track in
1992.
there are a lot of companies that don't
have the option of shutting down
they make things that people need we're
being asked by
global governments to stay open to make
sure that food could get
to the consumers
the food supply chain is complicated
there's a lot of
steps in the process from the cattle
ranchers and poultry farmers
and the feed producers that make the
feed for the livestock
and the farmers that tend to the
livestock
and then to the production facilities
and then ultimately to the
transportation system that bring them to
the stores
the number of coronavirus cases in the
united states is growing
exponentially store shelves nationwide
are dwindling or totally empty
people start panic buying anything and
everything
it starts to feel a little bit like end
times pantry loading or panic buying
increased consumption beyond what we
could make in any given week
and so inventories were drawn down
[Music]
that did put a lot of pressure into the
system for us to maximize production
what we wanted to do is get the assets
that we had running
24 hours a day seven days a week and
they increased production by several
million cases across our total system
these companies have to stay open their
first priority is keeping their
employees safe and keeping the business
operating
we moved quickly early on to get as much
ppe
as we could personal protective
equipment to
take temperatures from you know amongst
people going in
and if anyone showed any symptoms they
could not go back in
we added plastic shields in between the
workers on the line
in the back your mind you hold on
optimism maybe we'll get through this
with
nobody getting impacted nobody getting
infected
but when you have 160 000 employees that
are
out and about not only in our facilities
but in their own communities
you realize the odds of that are very
low
and then there are the companies that
we're all turning to to fix this
you've got companies making mass and
respirators you've got pharmaceutical
companies
who are getting to work on treatments so
these are companies that not only do
they not have the option of shutting
down
the entire world is looking at them and
saying this is not just a business
question for you this is like this is an
existential thing that we need you to do
you have to do a better job than you
used to do and do it under unbelievably
trying circumstances
we have a few late stage phase three
clinical trials at repurposing medicines
and then we have a very large drug
discovery effort
trying to see can we find what we call a
pan coronavirus drug
it requires new scientific discoveries
new scale up new clinical trials
and that is a much bigger challenge
because now you're asking
clinical trial sites that are now
focused on trying to respond to a
pandemic
to get a trial up and running can you
still
enroll patients into the study if health
care systems are closing down
the number of cases soaring just today
more than 24 000 now nationwide
new jersey today becoming the sixth
state to close all non-essential
businesses
the president invoked the defense
production act to prioritize production
of items under government contracts
and to allocate scarce items where they
are needed most
the order authorizes the head of fema to
acquire as many
n95 masks from the company 3m
as is deemed necessary
we had significantly increased the
production rate
for respirators here in the u.s we'd
gone from maybe 22 million
in january to more than 35 million in
march
we could see that this was was really
coming at us pretty
fast here in the us so not only are we
looking at how do we continue to drive
up manufacturing
of our own products but also what else
can we do from other
parts of the world so it doesn't take
long
before you start hearing talk of
bailouts
the airline industry alone seeking a 50
billion
bailout but should these companies get
relief with no strings attached
the industry as a whole came together in
a remarkable way
ceos from every airline were down in
washington trying to make sure that
all the decision makers understood how
vital and critical the airline industry
is to this economy
we were number one really in reinforcing
with the administration that
the employment situation was going to be
dire that our industry
was going to lose millions and millions
of jobs and we needed
the federal government to help take care
of those teams
[Music]
the employees are the ones most hit by
this when you lay off 62 000 employees
it's meaningful i'll give the federal
government credit the cares act came
together fairly quickly
well thank you all very much is a very
important day i'll sign the single
biggest economic relief package
in american history and i must say or
any other package by the way
so on march 27th president trump signs
the
two trillion dollar coronavirus aid
package the cares act into law this
dwarfs
any kind of stimulus that was handed out
during the 2008 financial crisis so it
involves includes
billions of dollars for airlines for
hospitals for state and local
governments
it has a large small business lending
program that's meant to sort of
keep paying people who would otherwise
have been laid off
this is a massive amount of government
spending and it's meant to put a
band-aid over this
broken economy part of what we've had to
take a very hard look at is how we make
the
payroll dollars under the cares act work
well for us
and you know really be clear with our
crew members about what we expect
the future to hold we have not ever
advocated for any
sort of help from the government for
hilton and so what we were advocating
there on behalf of our owners many of
whom are small
medium-sized you know entrepreneurially
based businesses was
we need to help create a bridge of
liquidity to help them get to the other
side
one of the things that's so interesting
about the monetary and fiscal policy is
it's really created liquidity
and support for large businesses it's
allowed large businesses even those that
are in distress
to finance forward very very actively
but small businesses and especially very
small businesses are just devastated
by this crisis
[Music]
and the worst part is by late march it's
clear that this isn't over
and that it's time to start packing
sandbags we had
around 380 million dollars in cash
and we looked at our burn rate and we
concluded
that without you know massive layoffs
and things like that
we probably spend about 10 million
dollars a month
so we looked at it and we said we have
about two and a half years
in a zero revenue environment and that
was a really important element for us
because at that time the street and
constituencies were really focused on
how long
companies could survive and would they
be going out of business and i think
that was a really important message for
us that we had the money to survive
we were fortunate uh last year we sold
off uh about eight billion dollars worth
of real estate with that eight billion
we sold down some debt
but between what we left and a bond
offering we just did
for 750 million we're sitting on about
4.6 billion in capital
and liquidity so we have money to
sustain this
and it will guide what we do going
forward
the thing that's really different about
this pandemic is that it is global
and that the demand has been so high
quadrupling of capacitor of output
from 3m is still not sufficient
the the increase in manufacturing from
even some of our competitors
is still not sufficient to meet the
demand a lot of focus
came on the the meat production industry
because
so many facilities had been shutting
down union officials now say
164 of the nearly 900 workers at the
cargill meat packing plant
have tested positive for the coronavirus
the facility we closed
in pennsylvania came back on after 17
days
and is back running again so i think
that's the best thing we can do as an
industry is
get adequate testing continue to have
adequate ppe
but get the plants up and running as
quickly as possible so that
store shelves can stay stocked
[Music]
there's really no way in a pandemic to
keep everyone safe if people have to be
gathering if they have to be working in
a factory or working in a retail store
there's always risk
[Music]
what kept us up at night was figuring
out if there was in fact
a safe and healthy way to return to play
there is no guarantee that you can do it
in a hundred percent
safe way and so this is literally
matters of life and death
and so that weighs on you because you
don't want to put
anybody at risk that
is what makes the weight of these
decisions so heavy
we lost an empire casino one of our
places back in
new york we lost a horseman and so it
was actually the first death within
our family it just took on a different
context from that point
and you began to realize the
responsibility of your not only
accountable to a business but at this
point
you're accountable for lives
when we lost our first crew member that
frightened so many crew members but also
brought home the reality of this
pandemic and that
it wasn't going away one of the stories
that
really hit me was the first death we had
at one of our production sites
i think this was a moment where it
became very real
that we have this difficult balance to
walk we make these medicines
that hundreds of millions of people
depend on
and yet at the same time we want to
protect the people who come
bravely into the office into the
manufacturing sites or
our clinical trial sites or the
healthcare workers who are working
bravely
to keep the hospitals running
there's no magic bullet there's no magic
vaccine or therapy
it's just behaviors on march 31st last
day of the month the u.s overtakes china
in the official death count
total number of confirmed cases at that
point are 160
000 which is the most of any country in
the world american business comes into
march writing
an 11-year economic expansion by the end
of the month
the economy is in tatters 10 million
people had lost their jobs
unemployment numbers are at
unprecedented levels the drive through
a symbol of america's capitalist
invention
now being used to process its millions
of unemployed
applications literally about a third
of american workers were vulnerable
vulnerable either to
being laid off vulnerable to furloughs
vulnerable to reduced work hours now
that's clearly a much
larger number than actual unemployment
the 500 largest companies in the us are
worth three trillion dollars less than
they were
before the month began the market which
had just been at all-time highs in
february
is you know officially in in a bear
market
territory 20 off from the peak
the pandemic closed the book on one
chapter for american business the decade
that preceded it
was one of the most successful in
history and
it ended quickly that's a lot of
whiplash for business to
absorb
given our access to information because
we have such a big footprint in asia
why did all of us and by the way not
just all of us
but so many feel that the chance of this
spreading into a global pandemic was low
we all tend to look at things
through a lens of the experiences that
we've had
the difference is we are much more
globally connected from air travel the
way supply chains work
now than perhaps 10 or 12 years ago when
sars and mares were really taking place
we've seen the market hit record high
after record high since march but
there's a lot of rebuilding to do
and companies are now grappling with
what kind of foundation they're
rebuilding on
what might prove to be features of the
economy coming out of this
one is the idea of what do we think of
as essential infrastructure essential
capabilities for
a company we've now already discovered
that in fact
the probably the most essential
infrastructure in this moment is
actually digital infrastructures
i don't think you're going to see
investments in digitization slow down
actually i think they may continue to
accelerate
one of the things that we're thinking
about is how do you continue to engage
fans how do you continue to engage
people who love your sport
who can't actually be there physically
and and this is
why technology i think and the
integration of that technology
those are the kinds of innovations that
have come out of this pandemic
i think one of the capabilities that i
think companies are going to now have to
think
hard about and build for which is how do
we build resilience
even if it comes at the expense of some
efficiency
the toyota way of production including
just in time
supply of parts or or rigorous focus on
very efficient manufacturing that's not
going to change
what may change within that is how we
support our partners our suppliers to be
resilient
in order to in provide
parts and production it takes
in a place like this in bellagio about
70
normally just to break even these are
large ships if you will
and so to the extent we're not in that
mode we're probably not making money
our principle is going to be it's going
to be some time before we get there
and so how can we look at this operation
how can we look at this business
and re-gear it so that we can do that
much more effectively at a much lower
occupancy rate
i think there's been some other
different kinds of changes at the level
of society and the economy
it's become even more apparent about the
often the disconnect
that happens between uh successful
corporations
and successful parts of the economy and
the parts of society that get left
behind
those might have been abstract kind of
conversations
uh in a kind of theoretical abstract way
but i think most business leaders have
come into personal direct
experience with that in this moment this
won't last forever
um and some companies will be better for
it
some will be stronger for having sort of
planned and been flexible and gotten
through it
and some will just never come back as an
investments business
we teach our clients to look at the
long-term goal
and i think that's how you run a
business you run a business for the long
term you're prepared for the worst
this was the worst
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you